first up
some big some big news in science when
we think
of ancient times we all learned that
there were set
gender roles man hunt beasts
women make baby well guess what
usa today reports that archaeologists
are making a big
correction because they just found the 9
000 year old remains of a prehistoric
woman
buried with her big game
hunting kit that's right
ancient women were hunters too this
makes me have to stand up i can't even
take it
they went back and they examined the
remains of 27
other hunters and found that 11 of them
were women
okay prehistoric men and women were less
divided than we thought
and here's a look at her kit this is so
cool because
to you and me it looks like a bunch of
cool rocks oh it might have already gone
by
but to the ancient huntress
these tools can slay a mighty beast
makes me to stand erect it does
i'm so excited i just think that's the
coolest story
women hunters just yes
anyway next up i guess i'm the only one
whatever i think it's cool by the way
don't mess with those ladies though next
up refinery29
britain has officially declared the
granny underwear
2020 sexiest knicker
i'm so excited about this you don't even
know what good news it is to me because
i don't like andy's
going up my bum columnist georgia murray
does a deep dive
on full coverage undies and they're
having a
moment online shopping platforms have
noticed a 59
increase in searches for this type of
underwear in 2020.
let's face it women just called it
they're like screw it
who can you know who's gonna see my vpl
my three-year-old i can live with that
and the new styles featured comfort
coverage plus
otherwise known as regular
and they're amazing okay they do it all
no if ands or fully covered bots
yeah it's great news for me i actually
am concerned about vpl on the show i
take my job seriously
that was a big thing in the 70s and 80s
for women it was like
scary vpl was a thing i am so
excited about a woman who's going to
come on the show right now
because i truly fell in love with her
sometime
around april and i started pitching her
for the show i always would say
do you think people will ever come on i
assume no one's coming here and i'm
always asking very
graciously and she's going to honor us
here today
she found an incredible way to bring
both the indoors during
2020 and the outdoors together she
brings the art of crafty to a whole new
level these are i let's hear it from her
aaron sullivan i can't believe i'm
meeting her
hi drew erin outdoors i'm so excited i'm
fully fair oh my gosh i'm so excited to
talk to you
oh my gosh i love you you
really helped me during the quarantine
i marveled at your posts and the way
that you made
these incredible installations how did
you do it
oh my gosh well in at the end of march
as california was going into lockdown
and i i was watching my work calendar
evaporate
so i was thinking about ways that i
could stay creative and stay connected
to travel and the outdoors and so i
decided to try to
create believable outdoor scenes using
household items like
that's parsley this is a cookie
and you know let's see what our next one
is
um you make the this one i loved
this is paper bags right yep so that's a
paperback canyon so i was thinking about
the canyons in the southwest
rosemary yep rosemary
i mean they're just so and oh this one
is a classic your pancake
mountains i mean yes so you in your
life you are an outdoor photographer and
i've done a deep dive through your
instagram
and you look like you're living a dream
life but it was not exactly that at the
beginning
well i loved photography from an early
age but i was so afraid to
make it into a successful career you
know you hear that art is
really hard to make into a business so i
kind of ran from it
and i pursued an adjacent career in
outdoor education which
let me travel but i kind of think when
you avoid your passion and your purpose
it'll just come to bite you and that's
totally what happened to me
i got let go from my first and only
office job and decided to pursue it from
there
well what you are bringing to the world
is just imaginative and beautiful
and i love that when you're so good at
what you do
out in the world that you can somehow
bring it in
and reimagine it with household
materials you really brought me through
the quarantine i can't wait
to see more i can't wait until you get
outdoors again but
when i just look at you i'm just like
you are living
a dream and a truth and it's nice to
know that you had to be brave enough to
find that because
we all need to hear that thanks so much
yeah no you're amazing i can't believe
i'm talking to you i'm going to freak
out afterwards and
i'd love to stay in touch thank you erin
outdoors
is her instagram account you can find it
on our website and i'm honored to meet
you let it not be the last
time you're so cool